for the very first time here on the show
or for quite some time the new New
Orleans Saints quarterback who I had a
good chance to hang with two times last
year calling a couple of his games and
was great to see him then and a great to
chat with him now he's Jameis Winston
how are you James I am fine I am fine my
family is well I'm asking you the same
how is everything in your world with
your family my parents are locked up in
Alabama and my family here in Tampa we
were really really having a tough time
keeping up with a warrior's got to be
two in a cup when my word game oh boy
yeah quarantine with a baby and it's
true you got married right did you get
married in the midst of all this - yes
sir I did we had a quarantine wedding in
my backyard
what is that what did that look like was
that like in a mini intermediate family
my intermediate family and about and you
got American my pool I had Campbell's
around some rose petals in the pool we
had one of one of my best friends who's
like my life coach the Barney design
chaplain emeritus right up on about nine
eight-foot parts we had a my dog she
walked in with me and I had to add the
DJ I was a DJ and everything playing the
music when I walked out and when my wife
walked out and he just we had a good
time so that's how enrolled so DJ
hopeless romantic Jameis Winston here on
the Rich Eisen show that's how I should
I should I should run it that's how I
should refer to you is that wow that's
quite something Jameis that's great it's
and you know yeah I mean so well how
would you call I guess the last month
month and a half of your life man
would you term it as last month I would
call it a month a month of resilience
right because uh I'm always the person I
know it's bigger than me right despite
what I been going through professionally
mentally I think this century had well
this room has been suffering way more
than me which allowed me to be grateful
for all the opportunities and all the
people especially on the front lines
that are helping you know protect us and
helping serve this country to the best
of their abilities going over and beyond
their job and their their duties to help
us so I just I call it a month of
resilience this decision that that is
for me that led with me choosing the New
Orleans Saints is definitely definitely
a resilient step in my book because I
get a chance to be with the team who one
who who wants me to a coach that's a
future hall-of-fame coach and three and
in part of the one the big one is a Hall
of Fame quarterback group who has
inspired me my entire life
it's opportunity for me but even during
this time of me thinking about me I
can't because there's so much going on
in this world and I'm so grateful for
the people that we have here now look
you are a bus you're yeah and I think
that's an excellent response to the way
I ask the question because again you are
a blessed man you're blessed with
god-given talents and you just mentioned
what your you just had in terms of your
your wedding and your family is healthy
and we do know what's going on in the in
the world and what this means and again
this is a game obviously the NFL but it
is your life and your business and your
and your career so put it all together
did did Sean Payton or the Saints did
you ask if there was more than just a
year like that could this lead to you
the next starting quarterback of the New
Orleans Saints knowing that Brees might
have a career in broadcast waiting for
him whenever you know he does have a
reading for him when he wants it you
know that was that wasn't even you know
on my mind you know what was where he
was the opportunity and when I talked to
coach Payne he gave it to me you know
straight forward and he said one thing
that I really admire is a chance to
compete the chance to compete with an
amazing quarterback room and learn from
the best
and I think that that really sold me
because I've been playing against them
for five years and I'm a firm believer
in in that Roman and what Drew has done
and that he has done have you had
conversations with him with Drew yeah
you connected with him I've spoken over
the years and he just welcomed me to to
the Saints now any of this fact that you
signed with the Saints have to do with
the fact that you stay in the same
division and you might have an
opportunity to face your former team
Jameis Winston it's not just about you
know beating the books twice a year
every year for the rest of my life but
it's about it's about being in that same
division you know being familiar with
being an NFC South and playing as
Carolina even though they have a boot
coaching change in Atlanta just being
able to learn from a guy that it's going
to be playing as similar things that
I've been playing planning it I think
that was extra opportunity for me so
when I asked you to playing against them
you said beating them twice a year for
the rest of your life I did I think I
did hear that correctly correct it's not
like you know hey you might see him
every now and then note twice a year
you're gonna beat them and for the rest
of your life
so how do you feel about the Buccaneers
right now Jameis I mean like
I'm man I'm grateful the glaziers gave
me opportunity that that I dreamed of
all right Jason life gave me opportunity
with coach Larry Smith back in 2015 and
it was amazing I love my teammates and
and that's always gonna be the case
that's always gonna be the case I love
this city of Tampa Bay in the excellent
five years and me just learning and
growing and meeting new people but at
the end of the day they're competition
this is my profession and this is my
career and they gave me opportunity and
someone else has given the opportunity
now so I am lawyer to them and I'm doing
my best to be the best teammate and best
football player possible to help serve
the Saints the best I can
a few more minutes left with Jameis
Winston here on the Rich Eisen show so
much made of your LASIK surgery Jameis
do you think that your eyesight had
something to do with your your turnover
rate last year I mean I'll just go
straight forward and that's what people
are putting them together here okay I'm
not making excuses but I am going to get
better but I'm not gonna make a make an
excuse I can say that the LASIK has
definitely helped my vision and my
accuracy so I can I can say that I can
honestly say that because that's what
I've experienced I didn't have my whole
life now I got better eyes well I mean
no so so did you wear contacts during
games is that what you you know I I
tried I tried I tried my first well I
talked to one year I think about my 30
year interesting way not not like I
don't really blink much they were
falling out like they were uncomfortable
I just ironed out of you're lazy like
this I guess anything they can help my
game to help me seem more precise like
how I was not used to the fact because I
was like hey I don't have you guys know
bike you know Bobby this far right so
after just doing the research
they're like why would I not you know
what I'm not trouble you have the best
vision that I possibly can so yeah look
I'm married to a woman my wife had LASIK
surgery after wearing contacts and
glasses or whole life I remember the day
after she had it she woke up looking out
the window from our bed she could see
like trees it focused through the window
I'm sure I'm serious I'm not being
facetious like it was completely
eye-opening to use the phrase so do you
think that you'll be able to read
defenses better with having not had any
contacts last year and now having LASIK
surgery now do you think you will
actually be an improved quarterback
because of it I think that it I think
that it can help certain parts of my
game in terms of ID in coverage and
entrusting my eyes a little bit more
because I would be able to see a clearer
picture cause I have so much getting
pre-snap breeze and you know finding
your post not answers but your vision
and how quick you process information or
how fast your eyes get to where they
should go next is very important so
being able to see a clearer picture and
get a fuller picture what that's would
be helpful but I got the kind of the
same storage as your life yeah my way my
wife moving saw books again in some of
those egg-white expansion and I and I
looked out the window and I could see
Matt by doing the daytime like I saw net
flying I like my work you feeling that I
can't oh that's yeah I got late there I
could you know look at you you're
spotting bugs now you're spotting bugs
Jameis that's amazing if you could spot
gnats now you could definitely see where
the safety is a little bit better I'm
sure that you know there's no question
about that
hey Jameis I appreciate the call before
I let you go I don't you know I don't
care who knows it and again I'm sure you
you didn't intend maybe for it to be
known although you did tweet about it so
I'm feel safe bringing up
you you donated autonomy to run rich run
this year
Jamis to help st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital I think you were you
also you know put it on Jerry Rice to
win his 40-yard dash in that regard as
part of the run I thank you that was
very very generous of you
very generous of you Jameis you know
I've been watching you run yeah and you
know I was just led I was actually my
friend he challenged me okay because his
friend was the other the other runner
against Jerry and and I remember doing
John broke for life of st. Jude and I
remember going to the big buy tales
event in Sarasota and learn about you
know childhood cancer and it just really
touched me so when when I when I found
when I was exposed to what you were
running for about my heart that God has
led me to forgive the man so thank you
for all that you do know to thank you
Jameis I appreciate that again it was
very very generous okay my producer says
we know of a photograph of your wedding
that we're gonna now put up on the
screen look at that there you are in the
pool that is a the flowers everywhere
candles look at you that's awesome look
at you roll my pant legs up I like it I
like it candles the voters the vote
what's your what's your wife's name
my name is Briana okay very good well
now she's married to a man who could see
Nats throw a Starbucks window there's
something romantic about to Jameis
thanks for the time appreciate it good
luck we'll chat soon thank you got it
right back atcha that's Jameis Winston
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here